you know there's a lot of people I feel
like Jeremy like me that I like hockey
but I don't really get into it until the
playoffs this is kind of when I engage
does that bother you or do you think
that that's cool I certainly don't think
you're the only one there's no question
and I agree with you hockey playoffs
there's nothing like it the speed the
intensity the drama the grace I truly
believe that you know there's there's no
sport that has the has playoffs like
hockey and you know it's almost like
watching the last you don't know much
basketball gave it to the last the last
minute but everything happens but it's
going to be even better this year i
think the matchups that that the league
has I think as good as the teats are two
teams in the playoffs this year Florida
Panthers in playoffs though this year
missed last year san jose miss last year
la miss last year so these teams are
three it could be awesome to watch yeah
we need like I'm sure somebody has an
app or something but I feel like Jeremy
I need someone to buzz my phone when a
game goes into overtime because extra
periods because that like even if I
don't care it all about those two teams
or care who wins even a little bit you
cannot turn it off when it goes that
sudden death period no was a foot out
question if you if you look at some of
these matchups and how they played
against each other dirty air there that
we could break a record for overtime so
that's that's just how close and the
parity in the league right now and I
agree it's it's gonna it's silent buy it
that will be the playoff time goes back
to five on five over time and it's just
a beatdown slug out vent is uh there's
nothing like talking with Jeremy Roenick
NHL on NBC nbcsn's coverage begins at
six Eastern as the Red Wings take on the
lightning and then continues at nine
thirty eastern as the Blackhawks face
off against the Blues Jeremy up you
mentioned that it's a lot faster
no the NFL playoffs are more intense I
don't know if the actions faster but
they're definitely more intense I think
part of that is maybe guys are playing
for keeps even a little bit more and the
teams are just better why does it feel
on TV or at least look like on TV that
the guys in the hockey playoffs and the
NHL playoffs are moving so much faster
on the ice because I know you guys are
still moving fast during the regular
season so why does it visually look like
it's a different level well there's only
so much you can do in football they're
what they're six second place five six
second plays and no matter how fast you
run with my heart how hard you hit
they're still stopping and resetting and
making a new down and you know all that
certain all the tangibles that go along
with football hockey is a different
story it is it without question you can
see the pace that's increased and it's a
constant pace and I think a lot of us
especially me we're enamored and off of
the case that they could skate it and
the energy that they can exhume for such
long periods of time and then you see
how fast what's faster the pump and how
much sharper the guys are and how much
better the passing is and put the
decision making because in the playoffs
people are prepared more they think
about it more they are more in tune with
being ready when the puck comes to them
because it is the playoffs it's time to
shine when the regular season when you
have 82 games it's very easy for people
and guys to you know to have let downs
and you don't show up one night not show
up another but you can't do that to
playoffs it's it's high pace all the
time you know I don't have any research
to back this up jr. but my my sense is
that of the four major pro sports that
seeding you know whether you're the one
or the eighth or the three or the six
means the least in the NHL playoffs I
know we've seen you know it's always
seems like there's really low C
reads that upset some of the favorites
do you think I'm right that have any
research no stats but it feels that way
to me would you agree that seating means
the least in the NHL playoffs I think so
especially now with the cap with the cap
air that we're in and with the talent
level that the National Hockey League
has right now any team can beat any
other team any given night and it's
without question there can be upset very
easily and even though you see like in
the basketball March Madness you there's
always upsets there's always some sort
of a you know a higher seed beating a
lower seed just a couple years back to
LA Kings they get into the playoffs in
the last last game of the season and end
up rolling through the playoffs and
winning the Stanley Cup as an eight-seat
it can happen can happen very easily if
you look at the Philadelphia Flyers this
year they've played Washington pretty
well and their team that's rolling on
all cylinders right now that fades
playoffs through a very gutsy team
effort the Washington Capitals kind of
limped into the playoffs they've had
everything wrapped up for months they've
had nothing to play for it's hard to
turn that on so you know you never know
so lucky flyers can step up and really
surprised the Washington Capitals
because of the pressure that the
Capitals are out there it's gonna be a
lot of fun to watch now we're talking
that's my squad do you think that you
think we actually have a chance with
flyers now that they're back in the
playoffs now that the back in the
playoffs junior and now I can say we
kind of like Villanova basketball
anything anything from Philly once
they're good at its we again do we have
a chance hey ruff of course of course
you do and you know with mr. Schneider
the owner passing away they have a
little bit more place for uh the around
the rallying cry sore speak but you know
this is a gutsy team is a team that has
a lot of a lot of hearts and they've
played really good hockey as a team and
in-your-face hockey hockey that's hard
to play against coming them stretched
obviously there
long shot but you know they do they do
possess a chance to win talking with
Jeremy Roenick NHL on NBC also has the
ronak life podcast with junior and Billy
Jaffe new episodes drop every Tuesday
morning Tyler Seguin from the Dallas
Stars joined the podcast this week check
that podcast out itunes stitcher
basically anywhere we're podcast or
found if you know how to get a podcast
you know how to get ronak life do not
how much of that podcast by the way jr.
is about your life off the ice I think
that's the part that I want to hear how
how much that is your talking hockey and
how much as you tellin stories from back
down today there's a lot of stories
without question is we tell a lot of
stories with our guests except they are
you know the people want to hear about
our guests for me it's forever uh it's a
it's a work in progress and it's me
telling stories it's made getting my out
really sometimes my outlandish opinions
my unedited opinions and I think that's
what people want to hear but yeah
definitely great storytelling some of
these guys are have such great
personalities their their stories are
funny there there shocking and sometimes
just you know it's just a lot of fun to
listen to so let's get to the
nitty-gritty of of the Stanley Cup
Playoffs is it going to be either the
kings or the Blackhawks again I mean
it's one of those teams every year is it
going to be one of those teams winning
it all again this year hey you would
have to think so you would have to think
the way that uh you know the Kings are
built that's a good chance however the
Kings are a very tough first-round
matchup against San Jose who beat them
in their season series during the year
sales a won three out of five games you
know the team that everybody everybody
thought was going to be great than
wasn't and then what was was anaheim
ducks I think the Ducks of the team out
west that everybody has to be right now
last question jr. you know we talked
about Kobe Bryant
he's playing his last game the night 20
years with the same NBA team I can kind
of see a basketball player playing that
long you know Cal Ripken Derek Jeter
guys like that 20 years in baseball but
there's a surprising amount of guys that
played 20 years in the NHL with this
physical as it is as many games as it is
you guys flying around the way you do
how is that possible I've always
wondered how a miracle without question
you have to have the grace to be blessed
with a very durable body you have to
have the passion for the game you look
at guys like yeah Mary auger and what
he's doing 44 years old in 27 goals in
six points he still led the Florida
Panthers in points now this is not just
a Florida panther team that has schmucks
this water Panther team won their
division a second under division or 101
year division won the division and has a
tremendous amount of youth and talent
and the army are still won the scoring
the scoring lead on this team that is
just absolutely incredible to me in it
and it shows how passionate they are how
much dedication there is to taking care
of themselves and you know it's um it's
it's really fun to watch now I couldn't
do it in court but you know some of
these guys that make sure every single
day they take care of themselves you
know they're the ones that are showing
but you know beating the sport well make
sure you take care of yourself over the
next couple months man I know you got a
grueling schedule on NBCSN ahead looking
forward to watching you yeah thanks ruff
their projection just taking a quick nap
getting ready to go work out and then
right to the studio to get ready to rock
and roll it's going to be an awesome
playoff series i hope everybody enjoys
it absolutely it is go time in the NHL
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
you